ja das ist eine weltpremiere wäre
untertrieben universum premiere mehr als
7200 kilometer pro stunde
mit dieser geschwindigkeit ist das
kupfer geschoss dass die japanische
sonde hayabusa zwei los gefeiert hatte
in richtung des asteroiden ruhige gras
millionen kilometer entfernt das
ergebnis ein künstlich erzeugter krater
und der offenbart jetzt super
spektakuläre erkenntnisse über die
evolution des asteroiden kriegs um
science-fiction gibt es spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks um
science-fiction gibt es jetzt übrigens
auch als podcast die links zu sport tv
und apple sind unten in der video
beschreibung zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der menschheit wurde ein
asteroid von einem raumfahrzeug
ausgeschossen das künstliche loch des
asteroiden ruhiger entstand zwar schon
vor etwa einem jahr aber jetzt liegen
die ersten ergebnisse vor und die sind
eben spektakulären fünfter april 2009 10
beschoss ein japanisches forschungsteam
den gigantischen brocken mit hilfe der
raumsonde hayabusa 2 und einer etwa
tennisballgroßen und zwei kilogramm
schweren kupfer scheibe diese raste mit
rund 7200 kilometern pro stunde durch
den weltraum und schlug auf hugo ein
dieses bombardement wurde auch von der
raumsonde hayabusa zwei gefilmt so
entstand also der krater in der
oberfläche des geröll körpers logo ist
etwa 950 meter groß etwa 325 millionen
kilometer von der erde entfernt und
befindet sich auf der umlaufbahn
zwischen mars und erde
der künstliche krater hat die form eines
halbkreises schon das ist seltsam und
ist mit einem durchmesser von 18 metern
deutlich größer als erwartet die form
und die größe des künstlich erzeugten
kraters verraten einiges über die
zusammensetzung von ruhige und jetzt hat
rio wo seine geheimnisse gelüftet seine
oberfläche besteht demnach wohl aus
porösem material wie geröll und sand
zudem legen form und größe des kraters
nahe dass ein felsbrocken offenbar ein
teil der wird abgefangen hatte heißt
also dass das projektteam auf einen
großen gerolstein getroffen war
so entstand also die ungleichmäßige form
die aufgewirbelte staubwolke die bei dem
auf
entstand offenbart den forschen das riu
wohl hauptsächlich aus feinkörnigem
gestein besteht das baumarkt verrät
zudem dass das innere des asteroiden aus
einem anderen material besteht als seine
oberfläche dieses sand artige gestein
der oberfläche wird wohl nur durch die
schwache schwerkraft des asteroiden
zusammengehalten und ist wohl nur neun
millionen jahre alt bislang ging man in
der fachwelt von einem deutlich höheren
alter aus nämlich rund 100 millionen
jahre
das ist ein krasses ergebnis röhre ist
viel jünger als gedacht quasi blutjung
die auswertung der daten auf ein bad
noch weitere super spektakuläre
erkenntnisse und die lassen das
japanische forschungsteam tief in die
evolution von regus schauen
anders als vergleichbare planetoiden
handelt es sich bei diesem aussehen wohl
um einen kohlenstoffhaltigen körper aus
der frühzeit des sonnensystems solche
sogenannten typ c asteroiden sind mit
den kollegen konkreten vergleichbar
damit gemeint ist urtümliches gestein
aus dem sich vor rund 4,5 milliarden
jahren wohl auch die erde gebildet hat
genau deswegen ist der sieg auch so
besonders spannend für die wissenschaft
denn man erhofft sich mit seiner hilfe
die planetenentstehung im sonnensystem
besser zu verstehen das problem dabei
solche konkreten schaffen es meistens
nicht auf die erdoberfläche
da sie bei eintritt in die erdatmosphäre
verglühen deswegen ist ihre physische
beschaffenheit weitestgehend unbekannt
die forschenden also bisher die
forschung gehen davon aus dass bei einer
kollision im weltraum mal von einem
deutlich älteren asteroiden abgebrochen
ist und nun als ein trümmer alleine
unterwegs ist das nämlich könnte
erklären warum aus verschiedenen
materialien besteht zudem weisen
gefüllte krater erdrutsche und einen
speckgürtel um rogers equator darauf hin
dass er sich in früheren zeiten einmal
schneller um seine eigene achse gedreht
haben muss die fachleute gehen übrigens
davon aus dass uns hayabusa zwar noch
weitere spektakuläre erkenntnisse
bescheren wird denn die raumsonde
befindet sich derzeit wieder auf dem
rückweg zur erde gesteinsproben soll
hayabusa 2 in einer kapsel mitbringen
und über der erde abwerfen das wird dann
nochmal eine absolute universum premiere
zum ersten mal haben wir material von
einem asteroiden auf die erde geholt
diese sollen dann natürlich ein
analysiert werden um uns weitere
spannende einblicke in die geschichte
des asteroiden ruhiger und damit auch in
die ursprünge des sonnensystems zu
werden aber jetzt schon ist das eine
wissenschaftliche und technische
sensation was hayabusa zweiter geschafft
hat erdgas retro erste bilder vom
millionen kilometer entfernten
asteroiden ausgewertet das ist auch
ziemlich spektakulär also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran